and I begin with two quotations which
cover I think important aspects of the
whole area of indicators ones from
guessing house and he talks about how
aggravated sorry aggregated
environmental indicators have been
defined as executive summaries of
complex realities I think that's a
succinct comment which reflects on the
nature of biodiversity the fact that it
is such a complex beast and that
managing it means measuring it but
measuring biodiversity is not quite easy
and yet you have to do it because
otherwise senior guys in policy space or
senior guys and business just don't know
what you're talking about there's no
point flooding them with complexity
because what they respond to in fact a
simplicity and and the second comment is
from sammelsohn and node house and that
talks about the power of indicators in
fact it uses GDP to make that point
saying that without measures of economic
aggregates like GDP policymakers would
be adrift in a sea of unorganized data
which kind of for those who are familiar
with the space describes the
biodiversity world today it's a sea of
unorganized data and you when I talk
you'll see a bit about what I mean and
they go on to say that GDP and related
data are like beacons that help
policymakers steer the economy towards
the key economic objectives okay so it's
a debate as to whether GDP is a good
indicator to identify the best policy
objectives for the betterment of society
that's a separate point but the point
they're making is that you need this if
you don't then you've got policymakers
in adrift in a sea
what is 40 in this space the key
challenge and I would say that the key
challenge really is it's about
measurement because a lot of what we are
talking about whether it's looking at
the use of valuation in policy or
looking at the use of valuation in
business or in local administration or
even in communications if you don't
measure how will you actually project if
you can't project however you actually
convince if you can't convince what kind
of management will you have and I think
that's really the essence here that we
need to improve the way that we measure
biodiversity otherwise we don't stand a
snowball's hope in hell of trying to
manage the kind of losses that piercing
nowadays improve the way we measure
biodiversity to ensure proper
stewardship of natural capital this is
actually a quote straight out of the td1
book and just a quick sort of thing a
quick update as to what are indicators I
think we need to recognize both the
measuring and the managing aspect of it
and we if we think of indicators as as
measures which point out the direction
of changes across different units and
through time we need to look at the
measuring aspect and recognize that we
are talking about measuring what is
happening to biodiversity and why and
then where is where is it going and then
we need to talk about the managing and a
lot of the managing comes down to how
will you communicate what you found and
the communication is actually key
because we are talking about
communicating in a clear and simple way
messages about what is happening to
biodiversity and why and that applies as
much to the common man and creating the
right feeling of groundswell of intent
and emotion as much as it applies to
policymakers as much as it applies to
businesses so these aspects of the
indicators that we are talking about
really have to be borne in mind when
when you're looking at this pace and
there are many unfortunately I talked
about key messages but actually that are
quite a few messages because we are
talking about how important indicators
can be in the whole challenge of halting
biodiversity and ecosystem losses
because firstly they are about
identifying the trends and the
conditions
very often we are about finding the gaps
and filling the gaps secondly it's about
measuring progress because we have to
look at the effectiveness as well as the
cost efficiency of whatever strategy or
policy we are talking about then thirdly
there about benchmarking and monitoring
performance so unless you know how
effective or cost-effective you're being
you're not going to be able to convince
a repeated use of the same set of
indicators for addressing the problem of
the policy challenge at hand and overall
really it's about policymakers being
able to get to grips with a set of
policy challenges they need these
indicators so what that does it is
imposing certain requirements on this
whole space of indicators because we
want to capture the overall picture of
what's happening we want to provide an
integrated framework in other words we
can't just have isolated pockets of
changes being measured and presented you
have to look at it from a holistic
perspective as what are the social
implications what are the economic
implications what you need to measure
specifically to build a picture and then
to provide the means of measuring and
managing that picture if you like and
that means that you need to go beyond
just the static picture as in what is
the status of biodiversity how many
species how much density of of biomass
or what is the the mean species
abundance you can't stop at just the
static picture as in the today's balance
sheet of biodiversity but you got to see
where the changes are coming from and
what implications those changes have
towards poverty towards well-being of
people generally and towards the
underlying framework of the natural
world and you need very often to also
understand your knowledge gaps in this
process because you will find knowledge
gaps and you need to set the baselines
because an indicator is always
describing either a space or a time and
there's usually a baseline there's
usually a reference point so you need to
decide what reference points and how you
select those reference points will make
a difference on your assumptions and
your and your management strategies and
finally you need to indicate them
because basically you are building
either a series of of
across space or you're building a time
series and those are useful efforts but
the thing is they are needed and then
the question is consistency because if
you have a set of strategies which is
addressing biodiversity losses and
challenges you can't have a different
particularly when you have spaces next
to each other you can't have completely
different indicators because otherwise
there will be confusion and there will
be not necessarily a good strategy for
overall reduction in losses so these are
some of the issues that that you need to
look at and basically what we are
talking about also is going away from
the biophysical indicators you need to
also look at the economic indicators the
macro including the macroeconomic
indicators how we reflecting a lot of
this economic invisibility how we
bringing it into the overall framework
because at the end of the day is the
same policymakers as I've said many
times before in any developing country
biodiversity strategy and development
strategy biodiversity policy and
development policy are really you know
two sides of the same coin you can't
isolate one from the other doesn't work
now what this means is clearly there's a
challenge in finding the right
indicators and the first question is
well how's it going are people being
able to find the right indicators so let
me give you a graph which is actually an
indicator of indicators so this this is
a graph which is from the UN which is
from the UNDP office of development
studies and they are measuring the
number of national indicators that there
are for measuring various kinds of
progress at the national level and what
it tells us basically with this sort of
huge increase that you've seen between
the 1980s and 1990s and now is that just
the sheer volume of indicators that have
been created is is humongous and that
also underlies some of the challenge how
do you decide when you've got 20
different indicators kind of measuring
what you're trying to measure but none
of them actually exactly measuring what
you want which one do you choose and
that's an actual challenge that
policymakers have to address from from
from their vantage and which specialists
and academicians and experts have to
help them address so this is part of the
problem the complexity is in fact
sometimes worsened by just the sheer
number of solutions that are being tough
to address that complex
so what all is out there well some of
the let me just identify some of the key
indicators that are out there being
discussed and which are relevant for our
world for the teed world if you like
there is the HDI the Human Development
Index interestingly this indicator is
not directly measuring anything to do
with the environment or with ecosystems
and yet indirectly there's a lot so how
many of you are familiar with HDI how
many are familiar with its composition
okay cool so basically you'd be aware
that it's got three broad components one
is an economic component if you like
which is basically GDP per capita and
other is a health component which is as
it happens measured in terms of the
longevity now you could argue that
longevity is not a good way of assessing
health because how long you live is not
necessarily means that you live a
healthy life but the fact is you need a
metric and that's what's been chosen and
the third is education and that is also
measured in a sort of not perfectly
satisfactory way because we measure
literally the number of years of
expected schooling and can anyone guess
which is the country which has the
highest schooling in number of years
yeah no but yeah you're kind of thinking
in the right direction keep going sorry
yeah Cuba not this one so you can't give
me the same answer for every question
and expect to be right come on think
again no way this thing you should say
that because you're from Australia and
the answer is it's Australia actually
yes this way I'll remember this though
yeah its large number of years I think
maybe it's because Australians go in and
out of school and go ahead for further
schooling and universe is total
schooling includes University as well so
there are these measures of well-being
if you like which comprise HDI no
schooling and Nature doesn't necessarily
have much to do with each other health
clearly is impact impacted by the
quality of nature and ecosystems and
clearly the ability of people to have a
high per capita income also has some
relationship to how much natural
wealth and how much natural product
flows into the economy but it's not well
captured so there are links but there
are tenuous links they're not strong
links and in fact this year HDI the
committee I'm part of that committee has
been looking at ways in which you can
get nature and environment more directly
into the measure of HDI and work is to
progressing in that in that vein another
indicator which is pretty commonly
talked about in the context of
biodiversity and development is Red List
the IUCN Red List which is really just a
scarcity indicator it's a measure of the
species which are either close to
extinction or are threatened so there
are these red list indicators another
group that somehow comes up a lot is
simply because it's measured sometimes
indicators are talked about because
people measure them so the the wild bird
index I mean why the hell would that be
such a popular thing it doesn't tell you
a lot apart from how many while yeah
yeah yeah yeah we know a lot about birds
so so it's like not not because it's you
know the inner some absolute ascends
highly important or significant but
because there are lots of birders and
they do spend a lot of that time just
measuring how many bird counts so
therefore we have lots of very good data
on this is time series there's the works
and it's geographically dispersed and
because it's a global sort of community
pretty much people use the same
standards for more bird counts so you
can actually compare you know whatever
barn owls in england versus barn owls in
Himachal Pradesh in India you can
actually have a comparable count then
this is useful but unfortunately it's
about birds so question is how good how
good are useful and indicator is that
and and then of course even from our
tier and Yale we've got dynasties oh and
other people's epi the environmental
performance index so essentially there's
a lot of these and it's quite difficult
to see the wood from the trees and I
haven't even finished so there's a whole
long list which will come up again and
again whenever you are in the space of
discussion of indicators with
policymakers you will see many of these
coming up there's a Living Planet Index
which is somewhat related to the
footprint the the global footprint
networks indicator of ecological
footprint there's the epi i mentioned
HDI various in
including the sebi indicators of the
European Union there's about twenty
three twenty six of them and then
there's a CBD indicators about twenty
nine thirty of them so there's quite a
few indicators which are considered
relevant for the world of ecosystems in
biodiversity how do you make sense out
of these well broadly speaking there
three ways of classifying all these
indicators so one way is to look at
which space which space of human
wellbeing are they impacting is it more
in the economic side low on the social
side or more on the environmental side
and of course you there's a kind of Venn
diagram which you can draw which covers
covers these and if you look at the sort
of cross between economic and
environmental spaces there's of course
not very much unless you go into the
green GDP and genuine saving space HD I
is sort of kind of touching upon the
crossover point between all three but
not really it's mainly between social
and an economic and then you've got
various indicators which are purely
social indicators you got green GDP and
inclusive wealth which includes a wealth
is sort of in the center space Green GDP
is is more in the space between economic
and environmental wealth and and then
you've got this whole armory of
indicators which is available for
measuring ecological and environmental
factors including the CBD indicators the
sebi indicators of the European Union
the Red List indices the footprint and
so on and so forth a second way of
cutting the same population of
indicators is to not say like which area
of well-being are they addressing are
they measuring but rather what are they
like I mean what kind of indicators are
they are they single indicators I mean
do they measure something like co2 are
they basket indicators are they
composite indices are they national
income account related so that's another
way of classifying them rather in the
manner in which they measure of what
they measure as against the area which
they their measurement can impact and
yet a third way is to look at this whole
idea of drivers and pressures in other
words are they helpful in measuring the
state of ecosystems invited
versity are they more helpful in
identifying what are the pressure points
and what are the drivers of loss of
biodiversity or are they actually
measures of policy response what's being
done about it and therefore what is the
impact of what's been done about it so
you can classify it in that sense as
well and then see whether they are more
about pressures or drivers whether
they're more about responses or the
state of biodiversity and the reality is
in fact that the whole space is complex
because you have to see what indicators
are used for and that's perhaps the most
important question to ask like who uses
these and why what are they use for so
you'll find for instance read less being
used a lot in the scientific community
in terms of identifying extinction
approaching species and so on sebi
indicators I use a lot in managing
especially in the European Union not
surprising when you host of indicators
like the footprint and the human
development which are there in the space
of public discussion but also being used
in in terms of goal setting and
policymaking and then finally there's a
lot which goes into just pure analytics
and good research paper so there are
there are actually different users
different users and different uses for
these indicators as well if we if we
look at what what questions need to be
asked when you are when you're trying to
either prescribe policy or evaluate a
local area and its its administrative
users or looking at a business and you
want to try and identify an indicator to
make it relevant make the you know make
that executive summary for the for the
people the decision makers that you're
addressing you need to ask some of these
questions like what am I using these for
can they be just can they be developed
to do the job has this been useful
somewhere else is this the first time
this is happening or can I quote an
established precedent of this particular
indicator being used to address that
particular problem and is it easier to
link them to smart objectives or is it
more difficult to do so is there a need
for this is this a great indicator that
deserves to be more use and better used
and therefore I'm trying to bring it
into the dialogue is there a best
approach or should I be more honest and
just talk about the three different ways
of
addressing this and that's a question
that you will have to ask an answer and
how do these reflect at different scales
is this a good indicator only at in
national and local level or does it
apply global here is it just only
applied globally and there's not much
point discussing it at the local level
so these are some questions that you
must ask of the indicators that you are
bringing into your discussion no matter
what it's applying to whether it's at
the policy level local level business
level or communications and you need to
deduce from the analysis of indicators a
few things you have to talk about you
have to see to what extent the impact
communications you have to see whether
they are really going to be useful for
addressing well-being because dialogue
is going to move in that direction more
more likely than not when when you're
addressing policy and whether they're
going to help you compliment or
counterbalance and then finally given
that the dialogue will get to the
national level and that there is GDP and
that there are well known defects with
GDP and the economic invisibility of of
nature and an ecosystem services how is
this going to play into that space you
have to address that so I think these
are some of the questions that you
definitely have to ask and from there
let me just look at what about us as in
from a teeb perspective what what should
be our focus and I think this is
actually a debate which is still going
on even though there is a view presented
in team report I must confess it even I
disagree with the consensus view I'm not
I as deep study leader I've always got
to go with the consensus view but i had
developed in the course of this debate
my own views as to what is important for
the team approach so let me just
describe that for a moment there was a
the consensus view was that from our
perspective because it's about measuring
economic value that we should try and be
as simple as possible and as succinct as
possible and really bring this down not
to a horde of indicators but just three
indicators and that was basically about
measuring three attributes of
biodiversity one is species diversity
for which we need species indicators the
other is just the sheer volume if you
like of the space that is occupied by
biodiversity hotspots areas of
ecosystems because
we know that natural ecosystems are
under threat and the area the rate of
decline of the area of natural
ecosystems is one of the measures in
which they are in which that has been
reflected and the third was the quality
of ecosystems which of course then takes
you to the space of the ecosystem
services it takes you to whether there's
resilience or not or whether the
ecosystem is close to a threshold or not
and it talks about just the sheer value
of ecosystem service flows that comes
from that ecosystem so these were the
three that the TD community decided that
they should try and focus on and
therefore you see a lot written about
that and of course when it comes to
quality that kind of opens the gate the
floodgates into the the whole area of
the MA service framework the tips of his
frame would derive from the MA and the
valuation of those and the various
frameworks and methodologies that I use
by team for these valuations so that was
the consensus view and we have to also
watch out because we are trying to be
we're trying to simplify the question is
do you want to simplify to a point where
you end up with the mistakes of the past
and GDP at the end of the day is a
simplification it's not as if in
creating GDP the creators were unaware
of the fact that it was an incomplete
measure in fact I think Sanjeev ute
pointed this out in one of your one of
your writings Yeah Yeahs Stone in when
he got his Nobel Prize way back in
nineteen eighty-four who was one of Mead
and stone with the two people two
economists involved in the creation of
the national accounting framework the
SNA as it's called and stone pointed out
in his nobel laureate lecture in his
speech that they work in the late 40s
early 50s was incomplete because they
hadn't really had time due to the
pressures of what they were doing to
look at the social dimensions and the
environmental dimensions and he said
that today as in 1984 there was a lot
more work available on the environmental
dimensions of the accounts of society
and therefore it should be possible to
make progress there but of course that
was nineteen eighty-four we are still
2011 20 27 years later not really not
haven't made much progress but that's
the fact is that even the creators of
the sna framework and GDP as its
bellwether indicator recognize its
inadequacy is now
question is are we in trying to simplify
biodiversity indicators going to end up
with the same sort of problem but on the
biodiversity side and the ecosystem
service I'd well that's something to
watch out for so how do we prevent that
work this is a personal perspective and
let me differentiate that from what the
team approach is the way I see it is to
first let's go back to this whole area
of biodiversity and you recognize this
slide this is one of the earlier slides
that you would have seen in terms of the
official definition of biodiversity and
how in order to encompass quantum and
quantity in that definition which is a
dimension of biodiversity is the amount
that you have the main species abundance
is an example of the amount it is
important because abundance makes a huge
difference in terms of how much food
fiber and fuel wood or how much design
inspiration or whatever pollination is
being provided as economic value by
natural ecosystems and abundance aspects
come in in very different ways so you
have to look at what is biodiversity in
terms of all of these three tiers of
ecosystem species and jeans you have to
look at their quality and their quantity
dimensions recognize that all of them
deliver some form of ecosystem service
and then come to perhaps something like
five fundamental attributes of
biodiversity which in my opinion cover
the majority of what you need to measure
in order to be able to manage so I think
you definitely need the measure of
species richness because if you are
looking at diverse diversity in species
then you're certainly targeting various
middle all the way from literally the
rural communities medicinal values
making use of those species for
medicines all the way out to ecotourism
values from species diversity and you're
looking at ecosystem resilience you
remember from Tom Barker's lecture in
terms of how important that the
diversity richness aspect is for
resilience secondly you need to look at
this this species rarity dimension
because the fact is because ecotourism
is important and because there is huge
willingness to pay for rare species and
especially species close to extinction
there is a massive economic impact of
that rarity and therefore you get huge
value is very often you see
these of ecosystem services and you find
eco tourism has massive values simply
because of this high willingness to pay
aspect or just the sheer size of eco
tourism in certain economies the third
aspect is what I kind of broadly called
biomass but actually biomass is both a
combination of area as well as of
density and biomass is important because
it's the fish biomass that is food is
the is the forest biomass that is giving
us a lot of the water stabilization and
soil stabilization and soil formation
functions of ecosystems so you need to
look at biomass overall and then figure
out how you would measure that and two
elements of that measurement is density
and I'll come to this and the examples
from the gist work green accounting work
that I'll come later but we have
actually got to measure both area as
well as as the density and figure out
how that moves with time and across
space the fourth dimension is what I
call primary productivity and there's a
lot of good work done on this there's an
index an indicator called hemp human
appropriation of net primary
productivity and HAMP is a way of saying
look a natural area produces a certain
amount of biomass and you can modify
that natural area by introducing
agriculture in some form or the other
you can keep modifying it but you have
to sort of work within the boundaries of
how much of the biomass that is produced
how much of the natural primary
productivity is consumed or preempted by
humans and there are points there's a
sort of diagram that you will come
across which beyond the point you will
find that the the primary productivity
declines and then it has to be really
fed in and supplemented by fertilizers
and so on but you can to a point feed
the human populations and maintain basic
ecosystem functions but beyond the point
you find that primary productivity in a
particular area will suffer and then you
need to supplant it without cultural
fertilizers and so on and prime
productivity is primary productivity is
important because it is finally about
providing food and in the case of
Fisheries I think this is also very very
vital because a lot of the strategies
that you heard earlier about managing
fisheries through regional organizations
and through local policy instruments a
couple of weeks back you had people from
conservation international talk
about that so these aspects are about
ensuring that primary productivity in
fisheries is managed to a point where
stocks are healthy and provide good
catches and and good economic returns
and last but not the least is genetic
diversity because that is vital when it
comes to bioprospecting and when it
comes to the insurance the underlying
insurance value that ecosystem that
genetic diversity provides that is
important so I would imagine that if you
really wanted to simplify you need to go
down to no less than five different
dimensions or five different attributes
of biodiversity and the the sad thing is
that if i were to handle not say well do
we have indicators for each of these
let's let's think i mean can anyone
think of a species richness indicator
yeah
it's a course kalyan and it will not
necessarily give you total species and
it will give you an idea in places of
you know where where you have the
information you not be able to compare
that information across geographies or
different ask different parts of the
same biome so it's tough Jenny we don't
so I mean yes those xicans are there but
the fact is that they are not available
everywhere so actually sadly we don't
even have and certainly not on a global
scale so pcs richness is not that easy I
mean you have something called the mean
species abundance which is kind of a
combination of biomass and richness but
it's it's a it's a hybrid and doesn't
necessarily pinpoint the richness aspect
species rarity I think that's probably
the easy one any one species rarity
indicators yeah Reddy's red list is all
about species rarity and that's that's
me up con not not entirely not all of it
but I mean there's lots yes
I mean redness will not necessarily have
insects and unattractive species things
that people don't fancy will necessarily
threadless Leslie so it wasn't you
amphibians are there yes rodents are
there yeah that is true actually are you
an appointment I forgot to penalize as
biased as I sometimes but it's not a
complete it's not a complete priority
the whole even though IOC has done a
great job on especially with birds and
so on but I don't think it's a complete
set of rarity biomass tough one actually
it's it's available there are lots of
area indicators available and countries
usually have these but everyone seems to
measure things when it comes to biomass
in different ways they cut up based on
different biomes they cut up based on
different geopolitical boundaries areas
area maps are available generally but
not on a consistent basis you can go to
google and you can get a good area
answer but you will not necessarily get
density for that you need to get into a
more complex technological space and and
look at satellite surveys and angular
surveys and so on and physical ground
mapping of density so even that is not
easy primary productivity well hand
actually there's a fair amount of work
on human appropriate human appropriation
of net primary productivity so there are
good scientific studies on primary
productivity genetic diversity also
again not not that well not that well
mapped so I think the point I'm making
is that yes there's some some effort to
across the world to have indicators
which measure what I would consider to
be the important dimensions of
biodiversity but unfortunately it's not
complete and in some cases just isn't is
in satisfactory so there's a huge huge
area of work research and quantification
and
analysis of what you've found and so on
which is still required to really get
indicators for biodiversity to capture
if you guys think these are important
dimensions of biodiversity from
especially from a the point of view of
value to human society then I'm afraid
we don't really have very good
indicators measuring many of these and
once again it's the question of seeing
what you have and trying to do the best
that you can and very often you come up
with the very unsatisfying conclusion
that this has been measured because it's
easy you very often will find that it's
you know it's the usual you know
birdlife phenomenon basically there are
lots of birders they measure birds and
therefore you have very good information
and indicators on bird life but where
you do not have that much human interest
so you don't have these these indicators
you are unfortunately swimming in a
space of information scarcity next I
want to spend a few minutes on on the
story of the 2010 targets everyone heard
of the 2010 biodiversity targets now the
the whole idea came up for serious
consideration at the johannesburg
meeting and basically the countries that
met their came up with this statement
which is that they had they wanted to
achieve by 2010 a significant reduction
of the current rate of biodiversity loss
at the global regional and national
level now can anyone imagine what was
complex about this statement what was
difficult about the statement or
challenging hmm sorry was that measuring
yeah yeah and in what ways well firstly
let's begin with biodiversity loss do
you think that at that point in 2002
anyone got a clear idea as to how much
biodiversity loss no oh yeah the what is
the current rate I mean if you don't if
you haven't defined like what is
biodiversity and therefore how are you
losing it how can you speculate and what
is the current rate of loss if you
haven't like measured it immediately if
a car is moving and you don't know how
to measure its speed how do you know
whether it's it's going faster slower
acceleration
waiting and here we are talking about
not just measuring the rate of of change
in other words it's the second order
it's a second order derivative we are
also talking about doing that at the
global regional and national level there
are huge assumptions here that countries
will be able to actually have the data
available to be able to measure what
they are committing to manage they are
committing to manage the rate of loss of
biodiversity and bring it down but they
don't have the information which we
should do it so the fact is that this
was recognized at the point that at
these nice words were coined and so
within a couple of years you actually
had two large meetings early in 2004 and
then again at the Royal Society in 2004
sponsored respectively by unep and the
royal society whose purpose was
basically just get some get some
indicators draped around this this whole
concept of of the targets of the 2010
biodiversity targets and they came up
now at that point they were it was a mix
of people so it wasn't pure scientists
it wasn't pure policymakers it was a
combination of all of these so what you
have is actually on the one hand quite a
rich mixture because it's not just about
indicators of the state of biodiversity
it's also about their sustainable use
and they came up with approximately 18
indicators which were being measured and
in many places in many parts of the
world and a whole wish list of many
others which was just not available
which they would like to for instance in
terms of forest area they had forest
area obviously in their trends in in
distribution of particular species and
they had deforestation rates but they
didn't have much indication of the
condition of forests or you know they
didn't have much on wetlands I didn't
have much on on the percentage of live
coral cover and we talked of course
information has improved since then so
even the whole idea of measuring the
components and measuring the state was
not complete at that point sustainable
used likewise there was hardly anything
that was actually directly measuring how
sustainably biodiversity is used
anywhere threats to biodiversity there
was some information and some
measurements on nitrogen depositions but
there wasn't much
on any of the other areas especially the
the extent of alien invasions alien
species or Road free areas or marine
fishing effort and so on ecosystem
integrity a couple of indicators look at
the massive jungle of indicators which
people wanted to measure and have
information on versus the two which were
actually already being measured so
actually the gap between how much
knowledge was available and how much was
desired is a massive gap now it's
narrowed a bit but not much and
unfortunately this is still probably the
number one challenge in this whole space
is the measurement challenge it's being
addressed by a whole host of
organizations under the umbrella of what
is called the biodiversity indicators
partnership it's got basically the who's
who of biodiversity is part of this
partnership so they are going about it
and the way it's being gone about is is
pretty much the sort of you know let's
get everything on let's get everything
that we can let's catch everything that
moves and there is therefore a sense of
you know alarm at just the sheer size
and scale of what needs to be calculated
because they are looking at not only the
status but they're also looking at the
drivers and pressures so sustainable use
is being measured threats they need to
measure it them the value of ecosystem
services are part of what they want then
they want to also cater to the needs of
communities basically of tribal
communities and our forest communities
and of course there's a strong interest
therefore in measuring the status of
traditional knowledge and innovations
and practices and finding out how local
communities are responding to
biodiversity and they even have
indicators like linguistic diversity and
the number of speakers of indigenous
languages as an indicator of
biodiversity it stretch of the
imagination of there but the point is
what do you measure again the point of
measure what you can as against what you
want to so there's an elemental measure
what you can going on yes you can count
the number of languages and that gives
you a sense of number of indigenous
communities and potentially therefore
indigenous communities assume interest
in conservation and so on so there's
there's that element of of catering to
if you like political groups as well and
then finally financing the size and
scale of resource transfer
into the space of biodiversity financing
what is what is coming through is is
that there's definitely consensus that
we can't only measure the state of
biodiversity we have to look at the
drivers we have to look at the press the
pressures and we have to look also at
policy responses and you would be
familiar from b1 and from earlier
lectures that this this image of
representing biodiversity and ecosystem
functions then identifying the ecosystem
service flows out of them putting values
to those flows getting the teep kind of
framework then feeding that back into
policy and then the policy feeding back
in terms of policy feedback and then of
course there's the usual natural and
human drivers of the change in loss of
biodiversity which then goes on it's
kind of a cycle of information and
response this is seems to be the
direction that most groups are taking
when it comes to biodiversity indicators
so that's as much I want to comment at
this point on the biophysical indicators
of biodiversity now let me go on from
there on to the more economic indicators
especially the macro indicators and of
course those of you are familiar with
this whole space of dissatisfaction with
GDP because of the lack of reflection
recognition and capture of the economic
values of ecosystem services will find
this deja view but let me just run
through some of the the key issues that
we have here which are that how good a
measure of well-being we ultimately
talking about making the case that
ecosystem services add to human
wellbeing for which then we have to ask
the question how good a measure of human
wellbeing is GDP in the first instance
so here let's look at some examples of
what gets counted accounted for in GDP
GDP is about value addition it's about
value addition so when people measure
GDP they measure for example corporate
profits as returns to dividends they
measure incomes paid or basically
salaries paid by by corporations as
valued for human labor they measure
interest as in financial interest in
other words the value for him for
financial capital so these are elements
of value addition which are measured in
GDP and the question is what's not
measured well
so let's look at two counterpoints for
instance if you if you have a situation
where government spending and private
spending is increasing because floods
and droughts have increased as a result
of you know natural capital not being
properly managed well that will actually
demonstrate itself as an increase in GDP
because you know it'll involve
government expenditure and involved
private companies reaping some profits
out of their engagement in that activity
but if at the same time you were trying
to reduce flood damage and drought
losses by increasing for instance forest
density and forest cover that effect
would not be captured in in the GDP
metric if you see an increase in medical
spending on respiratory diseases for
instance because there's more pollution
in other words more hospital spending
that will come up in GDP as an increase
in GDP but if you have laws and policies
which are enacted now for trying to
reduce ambient pollution levels or for
instance policies on our rules about
cleaner fuels for instance well the
value of that is obviously high to human
health but that will not reflect in GDP
if you increase spending yes question
I think yeah that element would be the
the if you if you could potentially
measure daily adjusted life years and
you might find an increase in daily
adjusted life years and that would
reflect ideally and worker productivity
and therefore an higher output but it's
a tenuous it's a sort of two or three
stage link but the direct impact on
human health and enjoyment well-being is
basically the question I'm asking right
does this impact well-being yes
obviously because your health is
improved but does it necessarily
increase GDP quickly no it doesn't
increase education is a tough one
because they recounted as expenditure
and this is the thing about accounting
and national accounting versus other
forms of accounting if you if you show
national accounts to the institute of
chartered accountants in any country
that they will always have issues with
the way national accounting works versus
the way that they would like companies
to account for themselves there is a
huge gap because national accounting
does not follow double entry bookkeeping
principles it does not follow clear
distinctions between expenditure and
income assets and liabilities we don't
have a sort of balance sheet and pnl
approach in national accounts that we
have in the case of corporations so
ideally when you're looking at creating
human capital by increasing education
expenditure that'll that'll show up as
an increase in spending on school and
university buildings but what will not
reflect in GDP is the higher future
income that you created in people by
adding to their skill sets which
therefore should be an increase in human
capital but that will not reflect in the
GDP accounts or in as in the national
accounts or in genuine savings and
finally going back to the tsunami or
going back to the Japanese tsunami oh
and there was a huge repair and
reconstruction cost and that it shows as
an increase in GDP in types quite funny
was a I heard an economist on CNBC
stanchart saying well of course the GDP
of Japan will go up now so the state
that with in a matter-of-fact way which
made me laugh and it's recognized that
when you have a disaster GDP goes up but
that doesn't mean that well-being
increases obviously it decreases right
because people have lost their lives
their families their homes their
livelihoods that's a decrease in human
well-being but it's an increase in GDP
in output now in the case of Japan there
was actually a loss in GDP because the
extent of damage was so
that a lot of production was actually
held up a lot of factory production was
held up in Japan so there was a
temporary blip a Down decline in
Japanese GDP but obviously the
reconstruction effort would lock again
and you will see an increase so there
are there are aspects of off of human
well-being which is what we are trying
to argue the case for ecosystem services
impacting human well-being there clearly
isn't a good measure of human wellbeing
being delivered out of the current
system national accounts so we are not
going to be able to make our case the
point I'm making is that with that
situation we are not going to be able to
make our case because again of the
economic invisibility of nature
addressing that economic invisibility
means going towards a different form of
national accounting where let me talk
about two forms of national accounting
which can reflect that one is sort of
green accounting and the other is
inclusive wealth so firstly about green
accounting let's look at it in the
following way there are all kinds of
ecosystem services which deliver value
at the simplest end of the scale it's
the value that the rural household gets
from harvesting fuelwood that's free
that doesn't reflect any where it's not
market price the question is can you
reflect it in GDP sure why not you can
always estimate the value and these
estimates can go towards GDP GDP is
itself an estimate I still remember
Sanjeev you were there i think or or not
but when we launched the first report
there was a lot of angst in india about
you know how can you how can you put in
such estimates into GDP and finally to
our defense from the audience came the
head of india statistical office who was
a man who writes the gdp and he says gdp
is an estimate I don't care whether
these are estimates are not the factors
GDP is also an estimate well done make
sure you disclose this point was make
sure you disclose your estimates make
sure you declare what your assumptions
are but make the assumptions and make
the estimates so
the DA sanctions involved as well so
with green accounting what you need to
do is create a framework which captures
in and integrates these ecosystem
services in and the the whole process of
doing that is mapped out at least at a
basic level by a manual called the SE e
EA 2003 the system of economic
environmental and economic accounting
and this this manual is is still at a
basic level because it doesn't actually
take an eco systems approach it doesn't
actually talk ecosystem services it
really focuses more on certain
categories like water and especially on
forests and empty umber and so on so
it's not compete in the way that we
would like it to be but it's being
upgraded and this is what i'm hoping to
get Glenn Murray longueuil to talk about
she's managing the World Bank's effort
the wealth accounting and valuation for
ecosystem services project and she'll be
a visitor at at some point either this
or next term so you'll hear more about
how they are going about this you need
to account for the externalities not
just in terms of capital stock as in
loss of forest in other words the loss
of capital natural capital but also
account for the floors the missing fuel
wood the missing nutrients and fresh
water the production of nature which
goes into value into the economy is not
accounted for if it was human production
it would be because you'd see wages
coming in or you'd see some kind of
output being captured or some kind of
company profits going up so you would
capture that as part of gdp but if it's
not human production but rather natural
production even though it results in
higher well-being it's not captured
today but the point I'm making is that
with green accounting you can capture it
you can actually work out the production
function and see the impact on
agricultural production functions of
improved flows of fresh water or off
improved flows of nutrients right so you
can actually work that out and then say
fine well these are components of
natural production which are adding to
human well-being they should be
reflected in the national accounting
framework you can use contingent
valuation techniques the usual
willingness to pay sort of thing which
you
as should remember I hope even though
you finished your tests and stuff but
that doesn't mean you forget them
hopefully you'll see that that kind of
valuation approach and work is useful as
as a means of assessing the value of
biodiversity species ecosystems and so
on and you can finally for any
accounting period firstly adjust for the
flows in other words what were the
missing flows that the that households
have received or that communities have
received or individuals have received
and account for those missing income
flows and you can also account for
depreciation because another thing that
the current system of national accounts
doesn't do is that even though it
depreciate man-made assets in other
words if factories are lost them yes
that would be accounted for and
depreciation is accounted for in the
national accounting framework but that's
only on man-made assets natural assets
and the depreciation of those doesn't
come in so even though factory losses or
or losses in in physical inbuilt
infrastructure would be accounted for in
general genuine savings if it was
natural infrastructure ecological
infrastructure that loss would not be
accounted for and that is that is a if
you like disparity if you like an
imbalance that needs needs to be
corrected so if you do all of these
things if you account for the missing
flows and if you also account for and
captured proper depreciation that you
are seeing in observing in natural
capital and remember its natural capital
sometimes it's an estimate usually it's
an estimate because these are usually
nan market values and that's part of the
challenge but by estimating the lost
flows the present value of the loss
flows using appropriate discount rates
you can work out the loss in natural
capital and you can start reflecting
those losses so all of this is is can be
done and it's basically this is the
framework which is known as green
accounting and what you tend to do is
you would reflect it in a framework
which is aligned to the current system
of national account so you would present
today's national accounts in terms of
green GDP and in terms of the genuine in
terms of savings and then you'd say okay
as a result of missing depreciations and
as a result of missing flows he has the
adjusted GDP and here's the
environmentally adjusted GDP as we call
it and he
the environmentally adjusted savings as
in genuine savings so that whole
approach is basically known known as
green accounting but there's another
approach which is in some ways ends up
in the same place but actually is
intellectually design somewhat
differently which isn't flow based in
that sense which is basically about
inclusive wealth a lot of work was done
on this early work by arrow and part of
a scope time and Collier and mailer and
then finally arrows been leading a lot
of very good research more more sort of
empirical work but applying the theory
and looking at how we can measure
inclusive wealth inclusive wealth is
just a way of saying what's the total
stock of capital available to the
citizens of a country divided by the
number of citizens in other words what's
the average per capita capital
productive capital available to people
and of course the current system of
national accounts does that as well but
what it doesn't account for is human
capital available and natural capital
available whereas the system that era
dasgupta and Miller have introduced
basically accounts for all of these
other capitals as well that's why it's
different that's why it's more holistic
and more more appropriate in capturing
human well-being because well-being will
come from various kinds of utility some
of these are it uses of flows coming out
of natural capital summer uses of flows
coming out of human capital others from
physical capital and the objective is to
try and capture that capital asset value
overall so that you can get a sense of
how much is the wealth of the nation so
they capture physical capital as the
system does right now but also natural
capital both dead natural capital and
life so they're counting for not just
forests and freshwater and Fisheries and
so on but also counting for oil and
other minerals in subsoil assets
implication of that is that if you mine
a mineral you actually lost it of course
you've earned some incomes as a result
of the sale of that mind material but
you've also lost the capital amount a
which is in the ground so you need to
account for not just one side but the
other side of the equation and then
about calculating human capital that's
knowledge and skills and of course
social capital which is a lot more
complicated when you're talking about
institutional and legal infrastructure
is quite difficult to quantify
even today when you get to this side of
the equations once again as with the
green accounting you will have once in a
while to make use of contingent
valuation techniques and to make use of
the other valuation techniques that you
are familiar with and finally you need
to present them in a form which is
digestible and that tends to be in the
form of inclusive wealth and you have to
bear two things in mind one is that
population changes so population changes
with time so if the capital stock of the
country is static that's not necessarily
a good thing because populations may be
increasing and therefore the average
capital stock is not is not increasing
and the second is the productivity of
that capital and therefore the total
factor productivity across natural
capital human capital and physical
capital he is also important because the
question is how much stuff goods and
services and and utility and therefore
well-being is being derived from that if
you are doing things which is which is
which are impairing or damaging the
productivity of your forms of capital
that's not very good because that is
impacting future well-being so we have
to recognize these two other additional
dimensions in terms of population as
well as factor productivity so let's
look at some numbers so this these
numbers are have been pulled together
from the work that arrow and and the
others have done can any of everyone
read them from especially from the back
what you want to come up front because
these are fairly interesting and recent
numbers now what they've done here and
I've kept some areas blank for us to
discuss but what they've done is to
calculate the domestic net investment in
these countries and the right-hand
column gives what is the adjusted net
investment the adjusted increase in net
savings so let's look for instance at
the Middle East and North Africa now
there they have a domestic net
investment of fourteen point seven
dollars per capita whereas if you work
it out on a genuine net investment
basically becomes minus seven dollars
per capita okay so can anyone take a
guess as to why this should be happening
why is there such a huge gap in the
Middle East amina basically between
domestic net investment on the one hand
and genuine investment
the other on the basis of what I've just
described to you what is inclusive well
Kevin mineral depletion absolutely yeah
that is a factor and it's not the only
factor so let's look at what's happening
here mineral depletion of the order and
it what is basically what they're
calling energy depletion that's oil
middle east is about oil right here you
see it that loss of oil that drawing out
of oil is actually being reflected in
value terms because it has a value in
the soil if it's out it's not there
anymore that means you've lost that
asset of course you've made some use of
it you've crystallized some economic
value by it's a low bytes use but at the
same time you lost the asset so you need
to account for that that's what double
entry bookkeeping is about you if you if
you debit some cash flows you've got to
credit the actual asset thing I reduce
the asset that you've got but
unfortunately because of the traditional
approach we don't do that in GDP
accounting bear in mind that's not the
only thing that's changing is not just
energy so if it were just for energy
that gap would be different but there is
one additional one which is education
expenditure so they are adding back the
four point seven dollars of Education
expenditure per capita so it's not the
case that nobody is adding human capital
human capital is being added as a result
of education so this is basically the
element of gdp which is expenditure on
education which is being added back in
the form of capital because you are
building that human capital and of
course this is the cost based approach
right so there you can also follow an
income based approach and valuing human
capital that's there's a paper by yoga
nissen and from a knee 1989 which is
worth reading it's very good way of it
specifies how to use the income based
approach for measuring human capital but
this is the cost based approach so the
answer out there is the net of all of
these numbers it's that plus this minus
this minus this minus this minus that
okay so that's how we do it I want to
just discuss one more country and then
you guys can play around with these
numbers and figure them out for
themselves but is anyone familiar with
Nepal and what's what's happening there
in terms of forests Nepal anyone
deforestation quite a significant amount
of deforestation so you'd expect you
would expect because of that
deforestation Nepal is the third row of
the third number from there so domestic
net investment 14.8 dollars and on the
right hand side you see genuine
investment 13.3 $1 now doesn't look like
a huge amount that would suggest that
there's hardly anything changing in
terms of natural capital losses but
there is something else can anyone
imagine why this would be even though
there is high deforestation in Nepal why
would the net domestic at the genuine
investment be not very different from
the unadjusted investment and guesses
yeah
well done that's exactly right well done
that's exactly what's happening because
there is serious investment in education
taking place so the education
expenditure when you add that back in
the pot is is not a small numbers two
point six five dollars and yes of course
there's net forest efficient so the
thing about this inclusive wealth
approach is that it doesn't really
recognize or at least doesn't sort of
address the fact that just by having
more educated people doesn't mean that
you can lose forests or just by having
more forest doesn't mean that you cannot
educate people but the point is it's an
accounting approach is better than
nothing it's better than doing nothing
on either of these counts that's the
point and that's why inclusive wealth is
is getting some traction at least within
the within the expert community and you
can see the rest of the numbers i mean
they're it's it's a combination of one
of the above it's just one or the other
which is always a key driver and then
there are other numbers so this is an
interesting approach which is being
being worked upon these days the data is
from the World Bank and I hope that when
Glen Murray langa comes in yes question
most of it isn't being used there so
okay the point is that it but the way to
look at this is that this is this
capital this natural capital belongs to
the countries of the Middle East so if
they've drawn it out and they've done
something with it either use it
themselves or sell it more likely sell
it right because that's where it's going
they've crystallized some cash value as
a result of that sale so their reserves
have gone up or their private companies
were operating in that space have gone
up the domestic components of that and
places like Saudi Arabia basically Saudi
Aramco which is getting most of the
money in so there is a value addition
that is taking place in cash terms as a
result of the sale of that natural
resource you are accounting for that in
your national accounting framework how
can you not account for the depletion of
that stock I I take the point on equity
which is that who's actually using this
in other words whose determining the
price at which this is happening and are
they getting enough for the oil maybe
not right that may be the case but the
point is they are getting something and
there is a way versus that of measuring
the value and specifying a value for oil
under the ground and you should account
for both not just one side so it's
basically the double entry which is
which is happening here in the interest
of time let's move on so comprehensive
wealth now these are these are study
numbers from the same group of people
arrow and the others and they're just 45
countries where they've taken this as
far as they can accounting for the fact
that factor productivity matters and
then the number of people matter so
here's the the unadjusted numbers that
is the comprehensive wealth growth rates
not those calculations earlier which i
showed you are in dollar terms design
percentage terms percentage per annum
okay and this applies across a five-year
period that they selected between
whatever is it 95 and 2000 Muslim yeah
so here were the numbers that they had
unadjusted numbers in terms of
comprehensive wealth growth and you can
see that some countries are doing better
than others China's hi india as high
whatever win as well as up not that high
but this hadn't accounted for population
because population is clearly changing
not surprisingly India's population is
growing fast
so that's one reason why is that's not
the only reason that's one reason why
you see a drop from 2.62 1.74 in terms
of adjusting for population growth but
it's not just about population you need
to also look at after you've accounted
for the population sorry these are the
population growth rate so I got that
wrong population growth rates in that
column then the net amount is after
population growth rate so two point six
minus one point seven for growth would
bring India down to point 86 if you
compare that to China they have a much
lower population growth rate and that
brings you down to two point nine so the
gap there is is smaller so then you get
to a net after accounting for population
growth or increase in or decrease as it
happens in comprehensive wealth but even
that's not the full picture because you
have to figure out what's been happening
to factor productivity productivity of
your capital during the process of these
of whatever policies you've implemented
during these five years so you have to
measure the growth rate in total factor
productivity once you've done that then
you do a further set of adjustments and
then you get to if you like the adjusted
per capita comprehensive growth rate
after adjusting for population growth
and after adjusting the total factor
productivity growth so you can see that
where you began with an unadjusted
number comprehensive growth rate and
where you end up is actually quite
different we see that as a result of
factor productivity increases in China
you're seeing their comprehensive growth
rate going up from three point eight to
five point six whereas in the case of
Venezuela due to declines in factor
productivity and of course population
growth which is everywhere you're seeing
a decline from plus 1.15 all the way
down to minus 2.9 for so there are very
significant perspective changes as you
look at these numbers in an unadjusted
form and when you start adjusting them
for population growth on the one hand
and for total factor productivity
changes on the other so this approach is
good because it it recognizes that now
having said that even this group has
only done these calculations for these
five countries so this is still in early
stages its formative stages right now
let me talk a bit about the ten sorry
that's
the full picture here so you can see
China 5.6 as against 3.8 and you can see
India at 2.7 versus 2.6 and then as well
are showing a sharp decline in flag to
flip as against an increase or decrease
in incomprehensive wealth secondly I
want I want to look at how we bring in
and think about HDI and recognize that
HDI is just an indicator which is why it
will not necessarily give you the same
answer or even the same direction of
answers when you look at comprehensive
wealth because HD is as I may remind you
is about a combination of gdp and about
longevity and about schooling right so
it's not necessarily the case that those
measures will give you the same answer
if you look at a measure like
comprehensive wealth and you can see
this in in the in the example out here
if you look at comprehensive wealth per
head versus GDP per head in all these
cases HDI is actually increasing but
it's not the case the comprehensive
wealth is increasing in all cases in
fact only in the case of China in this
example are we seeing seeing an increase
in comprehensive wealth endows in the
years that we are talking about 1970 to
2000 so there is a difference these this
is an example of two different
indicators giving you two different
answers for human wellbeing if you
follow the HDI route you might conclude
that everyone's doing better if you
follow the comprehensive wealth measure
which I believe to be a superior measure
because it's using quantity it's time to
quantify these aspects then I think you
come to a different answer and this is
possible and that's part of the
challenge
well it's a bit of both right its
population as well as factor
productivity so the reality is and
population growth is real because
resources available to the people if
you've had very high growth in
population there's less resource per
person so the fact that HDI isn't
actually focused on that is is probably
a problem but at the same time HDI does
look at two important things as in
longevity and schooling years but that's
not that's not a total picture that's
really the challenge with using an
indicator of the HDI kind versus using a
more accounting measure like inclusive
wealth and frankly from the perspective
and this is this is neither gay nor
there but it's a valid point to make
that if you look at HDI it'd be quite
difficult to justify required a tenuous
argument to try and bring in ecosystem
services whereas if you look at a
comprehensive wealth approach you can
bring them in directly through natural
capital and being one of the three
counts that you're looking at
I mean this is just visual
representation of the big difference
between GDP as a measure of national
performance and comprehensive wealth as
a measure of national performance you
can see that in some countries the
answers are somewhat aligned as in China
and the UK but there are other countries
like the Middle East and North Africa
where they're completely misaligned
Bangladesh where they are misaligned
India were there misaligned so looking
at GDP versus looking at comprehensive
wealth will give you very very different
answers for performance our challenge
today is that after 60 years of national
accounting based on GDP everyone's kind
of fixated on that the press understand
it's the policy but people think they
understand it the press the politicians
the decision makers and the challenge
here is how do you get a different
measure to be brought into mental space
and it is quite difficult and that is
why sometimes doing a big flip between a
GDP approach on the one hand and a
wealth approach on the other maybe the
more challenging route and that's why
people who are in favor of green
accounting including myself say that why
don't you look at green accounting
because it survived media it may not be
intellectually as clean as doing
comprehensive melt but at least you can
make a point relative to GDP you people
will understand it more easily who are
decision-makers who are not familiar
with the economics and accounting for
all this at least they'll understand it
better because they are at least
familiar with it's easier comparison
with GDP just a quick flick through and
I will try and be speedy because we have
only a short time left but accounting
for natural capital has been a key
recommendation of tiep and it's one of
the key demands that have been made off
tip as to get involved in this whole
space of reading national accounts and
where national products of projects have
become like in India it's very much
there they there's a target 2015 for
getting GDP you know in green domestic
product form as in green accounts form
by 2015 that may or may not happen but
at least India has a strong case because
some of the work that's been done by the
green accounting project for India which
by the way was a private project which
involved Sanjeev and Rajiv and myself
and a few others whom you've not seen on
the on the teep course but their
participants in the team analysis at
least that work is there so the method
or the framework and the methodology are
already there now it's a question of
taking the data and moving it forward
and getting more recent and better data
into this entire accounting process so
those who haven't seen these before and
if you're interested to pursue it later
on there are these six and assume to be
eight booklets basically these are
specific studies of particular sectors
like agriculture forestry there are
three studies on various dimensions of
forestry Education human education is
really important in India especially
because there's been a huge value driver
and fresh water the quality of fresh
water is is a very important aspect of
national wealth which doesn't get
reflected but the work has been done and
it demonstrates that green accounting
can produce meaningful answers and I'll
just talk a little bit about in the
remaining five ten minutes is everyone
okay for 10 more minutes yeah no yes no
maybe let me try to run through so
firstly oh what happened here looks like
we lost the map of India so that if you
had the map in here you'd see that
forests are fairly our patchwork it
covers ostensibly officially twenty
percent of the area although the
environmental NGOs will tell you that's
rubbish and it's actually twelve percent
and you know you'll never get the train
to agree because all kinds of satellite
measures get twisted in all kinds of
ways to come up with an answer of how
much India how much of India is actually
under forest cover how much is
plantation forests and non plantation
for us how much as dense versus open
forest and so on you get all kinds of
arguments is really fascinating but
anyone who's got difficulty measuring
should go to India because that
difficulty becomes difficulty squared
because there are opinions and views
which are directly in conflict with each
other so getting into Indian databases
is just amazing you know you the moment
you touch them you've made a political
statement actually anyway the quick
background on India's forest is that
they are significant within the answer
is twenty percent of twelve percent I
don't know and frankly we have to go
with a set of data because it's all
relative we are measuring relative to
one date versus the other so you have to
go with one set of data which you kind
of trust and understand the extraction
of and measure how it moves from time to
time the value of the forest deliver our
much is much higher than their official
recognition in GDP accounts official
recognition is only one point five
percent of GDP the reality is that even
if you measure
what comes in terms of agricultural
production and the impact of ecosystem
quality or Negra cultural production the
answers are much bigger than that
they're also very significant it's
estimated that something like 350
million people in rural India and in
forest areas depend on their livelihoods
on in some form of the other the output
from forested areas so there's a
significant social dimension here as
well which needs to be recognized and of
course there's the quantitative aspects
are quite interesting because state wise
now why States and why doing green
accounting on a state level well in
India forest Alice state subject states
determine how far is policies around in
our forests are managed so you can go
about measuring things on a national
level it's theory it doesn't matter
nobody's interested it's everybody's
problem and therefore it's nobody's
problem so if you want to have impact if
you want end-users to look at your data
you have to measure it at the state
level and this was a challenge in which
sanjeeva sitting right here had the
brilliant idea of going down to national
databases and drilling into them because
they're always collected of the state
level measuring it at the state level
would have meant one political battle at
a time 27 times but measuring it from
national databases compile at the state
level gave us the ability our group the
ability to actually go ahead and do
state level accounting while it's not
necessarily visiting every state
although we did detailed i did a visit
to himachal pradesh because we found
some surprising answers there but i'll
describe that in a minute so we have to
look at at the state level and you have
to recognize that there are certain
aspects of india's forest biomass which
are quite interesting one is that it's
relatively low density compared to a
global average and it's quite quite
significantly diverse across states
there are some states with less than
three percent on other states with
eighty-seven percent forest cover there
are three of these monographs of these
eight monographs are relevant for the
forest area and the framework that we
have set up for forest accounting
follows the SAE a framework but it's not
exactly equal to it because you need to
take it one step further se a does not
the SE a 2003 does not actually have
much to say about ecosystem services and
reflecting them in the accounting
framework and that's why we've had to
make our own statement
and assumptions now the physical
accounting framework for timber and
carbon is important because before you
monetize you need to capture physical
values as in how much carbon how much
timber and that's also an interesting
point because you can't have both carbon
values and timber values for the same
forest so we've taken the view that if a
forest is protected let's believe it is
protected and it's not going to be
felled for timber the reality is of
course different but then let us
calculate its value as a carbon store
and reflect that try and capture that
whereas if it's a forest it is a private
forest yes it was there for the purpose
of use and timber will be one of the key
uses so then let's look at its timber
value that's how we've gone about it in
this case then you have to look at the
data and the data availability is high
at one level because there are lots of
databases that are capturing it and is
also low in another way because very
often the databases are in conflict with
each other even land areas if you look
at the forest cover definition based on
the Agriculture Ministry versus the
environment ministry there are
differences the Agriculture Ministry
ministry's classification of land which
is forested is different from the
environment ministry's and you have to
take a plunge and say ok we are going
with this one because and state your
assumptions calculating opening stocks
that remember this is about accounting
so the first thing is what's the opening
stock then the next thing is what are
the changes that have happened and
therefore what is the closing stock and
then working out the changes in stock if
it's negative is a depreciation you have
to account for working out the flaws of
ecosystem services during that period
and those are additional flows that you
have to account for pretty much the way
that you do it in in double entry
bookkeeping you have to account for both
stocks and the flows there is also
unrecorded production very often that is
pretty significant and some of it is
logged so you need to put in estimates
of how much of unrecorded production is
their accumulated and how much of it is
lost in logging and these are some of
just I'm just taking you through these
those who are interested can go back to
the PowerPoint and and come to the
detailer I'm happy to discuss these but
there are several assumptions you have
to make like timber is lost due to
forest fires how much that's important
because that's
out of the degradation that's taking
place it's natural it's normal it
happens it's not pernicious or anything
but it's just his normal and yet is
quite different yeah it is part of
appreciation if you don't capture that
then your depreciation numbers will be
wrong and very often you have an overall
estimate and you don't have area
estimate so you have to work backwards
and find out what is your area estimate
shifting cultivation creates losses but
at the same time there is a compensatory
factor because people move and then
forests regenerate so it's not as if
shifting cultivation has only one aspect
of impact it has to there is a
regeneration of a forest in some areas
which you have to account for as well so
these are some of the the intricacies
that you need to look at when forests
are lost to fire how do you work out
carbon losses you you have a situation
where you have to make an assumption as
to what's actually lost of course the
main stem would be lost but not all the
biomass has lost some of it remains so
you need to work that out and put in
estimated numbers for that and so on and
so forth they're also flows from one
ecological zone into another for
instance some of the losses that take
place in the forest are conversely
increases in soil biomass so soil
biomass and therefore soil productivity
will improve if there's a forest fire
will increase as a result of of this so
you need to recognize that there are
flows from one ecological zone into the
other and map those because you need to
measure the impacts on the other side
when we talk about two methods these are
basically the net price method focuses
largely on timber and the weighted price
method which is what we followed focuses
on timber and fuel wood and the
weightages different and once again is
the state that determines what is the
weight age so the weight of fuel wood
which is a very important output from
forests and is again outside of the of
the economic accounting system is got to
be estimated and once you've done all
that this is the sort of result that you
see and this is basically a I think what
an fall kind of diagram which you begin
with your net domestic product whatever
it is you have to first subtract the
unadjusted GDP the system of national
accounts will have an a number as I
mentioned is one point
five percent so you have to take that
out then you have to add back what is
your estimate of the real income flows
if the real output of the forest which
is including timber fuel wood and other
ecosystem services add that back so then
you get actually an answer which is
higher then you originally began as the
value of forestry to net domestic
product and then you've got to account
for the losses and in this period as it
happened the losses were not very high
so the environmentally adjusted domestic
product EDP as it's called was actually
higher than the NDP in this particular
example but once again this happens to
be the case in that period and when we
drill down to find out why this was we
found that the reason for these these
are just the numbers we found that the
reason for these was that in the
northeastern states in India there was
actually forest accumulation taking
place which was compensating for a lot
of the losses in the other states of
India so once again an average Indian
number is truly meaningless because
what's happening in one place does not
meaningfully compensate the other
northeastern India is our natural
predation largely as you would normally
that we found there was huge
accumulations taking place there which
was one of the reasons why the answers
were different so there the ratio of
environmentally adjusted state domestic
product was actually versus national
versus the the net state domestic
product was greater than one and for the
other status was less than one we found
particularly that and this is the the
surprising result is that if we break up
these national numbers by state we found
that the northeastern states in India
were net positive there were huge losses
showing up in himachal pradesh and in
Goa and then the rest of india was kind
of flat so this was a very interesting
spread of results across States and we
naturally drill down into that and did a
and analysis I flew down to Simla and
spend a lot of time with the forest
department and thankfully at that
particular point the forest secretary
was a friend of mine so it was easy I
got at me if that had happened was
different kind of forest sector II at
that time but these things matter so we
got the story we got the story out as to
what is the reason why this is happening
and the reason is due to something
called the TDS that doesn't mean tax
deducted at source it means tree
distribution scheme
he my trepidation had something called
the tree distribution scheme where
locals were allowed to harvest wood and
the rate of harvest was huge so the
principal hardwood species called the
deodar was being lost very rapidly in
fact was being depleted horrendously
fast and this was the main reason why we
were seeing significant losses of forest
density so it was actually correct the
numbers the ground truthing exercise of
going there talking to the Environment
Department checking out what was going
on on the ground actually was true that
there was a significant loss and not
surprisingly it was being picked up in
the measurements and therefore being
reflected and they adjusted GDP yeah
well okay so we didn't know that but now
we do thank you yeah now the overall
numbers I'm sorry these a bit small for
those sitting sitting further away the
overall numbers are worth measuring at
two levels once again you need to
recognize that the adjusted GDP is a
result of original gdp plus the incomes
that you've not accounted for minus the
depreciation that you've not accounted
for sometimes one compensates the other
exactly sometimes it's higher sometimes
is low so if you want to get to the
truth you need to know both the changes
in flows that you are not accounted for
and the depreciation in stock that
you're not accounting for and that's why
it's important then you can see these in
the two different colors of yellow and
the fact is that if you look at capital
losses we are talking about stock
adjustments in across the whole of the
country at minus nine percent of annual
gdp that's one hell of a big number nine
percent of india's gdp were talking
about hundreds of billions and billions
dollars that even at that time that's a
huge amount of stock loss to take place
during this accounting period 2002 2003
and of course compensating there there
is some income as well so it's not it's
not just one sided but the fact is the
flow adjustments are small compared to
the stock adjustments
and they can see the significance but we
could talk about inclusive wealth they
don't know what they're comparing with
and even though the inclusive wealth
number is I believe a more scientific
and rational way of addressing the
problem it becomes more difficult from a
communications point of view so anyway
that was the that was some of the
results from the Indian study that some
of us had done a few years ago in in in
summary what did we learn from this in
terms of the experience of the green
accounting for indian space project well
i think what we learned is that green
accounting is possible but there are
lots of challenges one is data is
imperfect so the answer is not to throw
up your hands and say I can't use in
perfect data but the fact is data is
always imperfect I have never as a
businessman I've never come across a
situation where I had all the
information available to make a decision
you always work with imperfect
information so also it is in the case of
natural capital assessments so the key
thing is to be consistent be transparent
disclose your assumptions but make the
assumptions because without that you
just can't move forward second was about
transparency that it is important as
people have said to us many times they
appreciate the fact that we State our
assumptions and it's all there if you
wish to change them provide the
spreadsheet so people don't like the
rate at which you assume depreciation go
ahead change it it's your I mean it's
it's your exercise so you can change
provide the spreadsheets together with
the with the statement so that people
can make their own changes the third
lesson that we learned was comparability
and it is really important because if
you provide just a calculation of
inclusive wealth and it's not comparing
that inclusive wealth with anything else
you lose people you'll lose policymakers
because they don't know what you're
talking about it takes too much time for
them to digest if you compare them with
GDP it's a huge challenge it's a shock
to begin with sometimes depending on
which state they come from but they get
it and then you have a meaningful
dialogue lastly we have to pick policy
relevant sectors if we just picked on
species diversity interesting for
certain NGOs and interesting maybe some
of you and me but it's of no interest to
the policymakers unless he sees this is
important he ceases in terms of a policy
which is relevant like fresh water yes
he has water scarcity suddenly whatever
you are saying about fresh water quality
losses becomes in
for him if you talk about incomes for
the poor if you're if you've picked a
number which is important from that
perspective you will get across to the
policymaker because you've picked on
fresh water and you've picked on on on
the the wealth of the poor and the
impacts there and finally I think the
ease of communication is kind of
artificial because as sanjeev mentioned
a short while back in fact gdp is itself
an estimate frankly I think people
believe they understand GDP not many of
them actually do and they're all kinds
of things that are not that are done in
GDP accounting in India and other places
which don't follow the theoretical best
approach of GDP accounting they're all
kinds of estimates being made but people
don't know that so you kind of have to
get there slowly step at a time and say
that look you know here's how it's done
and here's what you need to change and
this is what changes are required and
the last thing we learned is that
resource scarcity applies in the area of
green accounting people ask as you know
there for instance i was once discussing
this with a friend of the World Bank who
was very enthusiastic about the waves
project night because she said we have
three thousand economists I said hmm
that's very good so how many of those
are actually natural resource economist
then she started Clowney's him maybe
about 50 I said great 50 is a good
number how many of those have actually
also got experience in GDP accounting
and it was literally like maybe three or
four so from 3000 we are down to like
three or four people at actually the
world's premier institution when it
comes to this skill set this is a highly
rare skill set and that's part of the
challenge getting enough people in fact
even with the Indian case it was
fortunate that we had people like push
Perlman and hari priya who had direct
personal experience of GDP accounting
and natural resources and therefore it
was possible to do this project but this
is a huge developmental challenges
people have to be educated and created
in this space thank you very much
you